so should we do a video about the Three
Laws of Robotics then because it keeps
coming up in the comments okay so the
thing is you won't you won't hear
serious AI researchers talking about the
Three Laws of Robotics because they
don't work they never worked so I think
people don't see the three laws talked
about because they're not serious
they haven't been relevant for a very
long time and they're out of a
science-fiction book and you know so I'm
going to do it I want to be clear but
I'm not taking these as I'm not taking
these seriously right I'm going to talk
about it anyway because it needs to be
talked about
so these are some rules that science
fiction author Isaac Asimov came up with
in his stories as an attempted sort of
solution to the problem of making sure
that artificial intelligence did what we
want it do shall we read them out there
and see what they are
oh yeah I'll look a little skinny a
second I've looked at them okay right
today uh law number one a robot may not
injure a human being or through inaction
allow a human being to come to harm law
number two a robot must obey orders
given it by human beings except where
such orders would conflict with the
first law law number three a robot must
protect its own existence as long as
such protection does not conflict with
the first or second laws I think it was
neros one later as well wall zero a
robot may not harm humanity or by an
action allow humanity to come to harm so
it's weird do these keep coming up
because they okay so firstly they were
made by someone who is writing stories
right and they're optimized for story
writing
but they don't even work in this in the
books right if you read the books
they're all about the ways that these
rules go wrong the various various
negative consequences the only the most
unrealistic thing about in my opinion
about the way that azimoff did stuff was
the way that things go wrong and then
get fixed right most of the time if you
have a super intelligence that is doing
something you don't want it to do you
there's probably no hero who's going to
save the day with cleverness real life
doesn't work that way
generally speaking right because they're
written in English how do you define
these things how do you define human
without having to first take an ethical
stand on almost every issue and if human
wasn't hard enough you then have to
define harm right and you've got the
same problem again almost any
definitions you give for those words
really solid unambiguous definitions
that don't rely on human intuition
result in we're
weird quirks of philosophy resulting in
your AI doing something you really don't
want it to do the thing is in order to
in order to encode that rule don't allow
a human being to come to harm in a way
that means anything close to what we
intuitively understand it to mean you
have to encode within the words human
arm the entire field of ethics right you
have to solve ethics comprehensively and
then use that to make your definitions
so it it doesn't solve the problem it
pushes the problem back one step into
now well how do we define these terms
when I say the word human you know what
I mean and that's not because either of
us have a rigorous definition of what a
human is we've just sort of learned by
general Association what a human is and
then the word human points to that
structure in your brain but it's not I'm
not really transferring the content to
you so so you can't just say human in
the in the utility function of an AI and
have it know what that means you have to
specify you have to come up with a
definition and it turns out that coming
up with a definition a good definition
of something like human is extremely
difficult right it's a really hard
problem of essentially of moral
philosophy you would think it would be
semantics but it really isn't because
okay so we can agree that I'm a human
and you're a human that's fine and that
this for example is a table and
therefore not a human you know the easy
stuff the central examples of the
classes are obvious but the edge cases
the boundaries of the classes become
really important the areas in which
we're not sure exactly what counts as a
human so for example people who haven't
been born yet
in the abstract like people who
hypothetically could be born ten years
in the future that I count people who
are in a persistent vegetative state
don't have any brain activity their day
fully countless people people who have
died or unborn unborn fetuses right I
mean we there's a huge debate even going
on as we speak about whether they count
as people the higher animals you know
should we include
a dolphin's chimpanzee is something like
that debate do they have weight and so
it turns out you can't program in you
can't make your specification of humans
without taking an ethical stance on all
of these issues all kinds of weird
hypothetical edge cases become relevant
when you're talking about a very
powerful machine intelligence which you
otherwise wouldn't think of so for
example let's say we say that dead
people don't consumers then you have an
AI which will never attempt CPR
this person's died they go and forget
about it done right whereas we would say
no hang on second today were only
they're only dead temporarily we can
bring them back right okay fine so we
then will say that people who are dead
if they if they haven't been dead for
well how long how long do you have to be
dead for do we want I mean if you get
that wrong and you just say oh it's fine
do try to bring people back once they're
dead then you may end up with a machine
that's desperately trying to revive
everyone who's ever died in all of
history because there are people who
count who have moral weight do we want
that I don't know maybe I mean but
you've got to decide right and that's
inherent in your definition of human you
have to take a stance on all kinds of
moral issues that we don't actually know
with confidence what the answer is just
to program the thing in and then it gets
even harder than that because you've got
zero edge cases which don't exist right
now like talking about living people
dead people unborn people that kind of
thing fine animals but there are all
kinds of hypothetical things which could
exist which may or may not count as
human
for example emulated or simulated brains
right if you have a very accurate scan
of someone's brain and you run that
simulation is that a person does that
count and whichever way you slice that
you get interesting outcomes so if that
counts as a person then your machine
might be motivated to bring out a
situation in which there are no physical
humans because physical humans are very
difficult to provide for whereas
simulated humans you can simulate their
inputs and have a much nicer environment
for everyone is that what we want I
don't know is it maybe I don't know
I don't think anybody does but the point
is you're trying to bright an a I hear
right you're an AI developer you didn't
sign up for this
we'd like to thank audible.com for
sponsoring this episode of computerphile
and if you like books check out
audible.com for do books and if you go
to audible.com slash computerphile
there's a chance to download one for
free Calum chase has written a book
called Pandora's brain which is a
thriller centered around artificial
general intelligence and if you like
that story then there's a supporting
nonfiction book called surviving AI
which is also worth checking out so
thanks to audible for sponsoring this
episode of computerphile remember
audible.com slash computerphile download
a book for free if you complain to your
bank then the strip club or and I will
just say we was with four girls all
night and 4000 pounds that's what that
costs at our place